maybe it's you again I'm building this
dollhouse for my girls mr. birthday
tomorrow I told my wife I'd get it done
it seems ak1 when I was a kid you want
some help big man no I could do this
it's just driving me a little crazy
where do I fix the princes Tower boy
where do I fix it now boil let it
brother breathe let a brother breathe
hey Sarge we have annual t-shirts in New
York you okay
the fairy princess castle has defeated
me I'm a grown man with man hands and a
man brain I should be able to put
together a dollhouse in less than four
hours why does it have to be so hard
this screw has three pointy sides
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Sarge I assemble the castle for you
well they were destroyed so I turned it
into a princess police station you know
some jobs take brains some jobs take
muscles some jobs take dainty little
fingers did I ever tell you how to wear
a woman's wedding ring Thank You Boyle I
appreciate it
you're good dad don't put so much
pressure on yourself Oh check this out
working siren
you